Oh Abbi you're so misunderstood sure you
can be a little mean sometimes but deep
down you just want to raise some of the
best dancers in America and there's
nothing wrong with that you knew from
the start that Kalani Hilliker had star
potential which is why you offered her a
spot on Dance Moms clearly you have an
eye for choosing talent because Kalani
was the star of the show you're here now
you have to be perfect
Kalani Hilliker was one of Abby Lee
Miller's favorite dancers proving just
how exceptional she really is after all
it's not easy to get on a B star radar
keep watching to find out what makes
Kalani the best dancer of all time she
stepped out on that stage and looked
like a million bucks unlike many of the
other Dance Moms stars Kalani Hilliker
got her big break while competing on
Abby's ultimate dance competition
although Kalani placed fourth in the
competition she managed to impress Abby
which isn't an easy thing to do once the
show concluded Kalani was asked to join
the Abby Lee dance company and to appear
on Dance Moms
Abby was smitten by Kalani's overall
talents and physique in Abby's eyes
Kalani has the natural look of a dancer
which is something she looks for in her
students I think she has that unique
special look now it's no secret that
Kalani was the strongest dancer on the
team and that's partially due to her
having more experience than the other
girls Kalani was 14 years old when she
joined the ALDC and had been dancing
since she was a toddler so evidently
Kalani was the star of the show she is
the strongest dancer on this team on top
of having the dancer look down packed
and being an incredibly talented
performer Kalani is also reputed for
having a stellar technique her movements
are calculated necessary and perfectly
executed which just goes to show how
talented she really is it's easy to see
that Kalani was trained to be a flawless
dancer who knows the rules and theories
behind every single dance
that's pretty Kalani is the best
called the answer here said having a
good technique would mean nothing if
Kalani didn't have the musicality to go
along with it but thankfully the girls
got musicality for days she connects to
the music she's dancing to on an
intimate and raw level which makes her
such a joy to watch on stage when Kalani
dances she's exactly where she wants to
be and it doesn't go unnoticed
well what did get noticed was that
Kalani sometimes appeared bored while
filming for Dance Moms and that's
partially due to her being one of the
oldest dancers there because of her age
Kalani took on more of a leadership role
than anything
although Kalani enjoyed dancing in group
numbers she much preferred performing
solos or dancing with a crew that was at
her level
baby Kalani's growing up as Nia would
say Kalani is a gifted dancer there's no
doubt about it but something magical
happens when she performs modern and
contemporary dances Kalani's floor work
is iconic which is why she excels when
it comes to these types of solos it's
hard to take your eyes off Kalani when
she's performing a floor number she's so
infatuated with the dance making it
impossible to look away the dance for
the beat Kalani was not on that stage
today when it comes to accepting new
dancers into the ALDC Abby Lee Miller
has a checklist that needs to be met and
Wow Kalani surpasses it we all know how
much Abby loves to teach dancers who can
contort their bodies in peculiar ways
while demonstrating profound flexibility
so we're not too surprised that Abby had
a soft spot for Kalani after all the
girl is a contortionist through and
through just like Maddie Ziegler
Kalani can evoke on stage her emotions
pour out of her making her look like a
light in the dark
Kalani can do this with ease because
she's a naturally gifted actress she
portrayed Sabrina on the TV series dirt
and Ashley in swiped but just because
someone can dance doesn't necessarily
mean that they can sing an act too but
Kalani is a triple threat if we've ever
seen one how about this role as I am
able
to dance but also I get to show my
acting
Kalani marches to the beat of her own
drum and her fashion style tends to
follow it's very rare for young women to
find a style that suits them before
adulthood the Kalani knows who she is
and what she wants to wear call her
Corky trendy or peculiar but you can't
deny that Kalani has a very unique taste
in fashion a handful of girls from the
ALDC created a dance team called the
irreplaceable near the end of season
seven only the most talented girls were
allowed to join and Kalani was one of
them after leaving Dance Moms the girls
went on to her Kalani demonstrated just
how talented she was by singing and
dancing for fans all over the country
but before she could tour the country
and join the all-girl group
Kalani had to learn the bases part of
the reason why she has such a great
technique is due to the extensive ballet
training she received as a young child
Kalani took her first dance lesson when
she was just 2 years old and began her
ballet training at the master ballet
Academy when she was 5 years old so
we're not too surprised that she has a
technique in the bag when Kalani isn't
learning new dances modeling going to
school or hanging out with friends she's
filming for her popular YouTube channel
Kalani knows what people want which is
why she has over seven hundred and forty
thousand subscribers on YouTube she
knows how to market herself which has
turned her into a reputable influencer
but what makes Kalani even more special
is how sweet and funny she is we love to
watch her perform and we love to hear
her talk freely during exclusive
interviews she's just so hilarious who's
your favorite Dance Moms star tell us in
the comments subscribe to the thing so
you never miss the latest Dance Moms
news and give this video a big thumbs up
thanks for watching we'll see you again
soon
[Music]